[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
this is the first time in american
history that law enforcement agents have
executed a search warrant at the home of
a former president a florida judge hears
arguments on releasing the mar-a-lago
search affidavit
plus the murdoch murder mystery
attorneys for disgraced lawyer alec
murdoch seek the evidence behind his
arrest over the murders of his wife and
son and jurors are expected to hear from
kobe bryant's widow as vanessa bryant
sues los angeles county first responders
over the sharing of graphic images of
her husband's and daughter's remains
then later i was very upset
and it it felt like the end of our
friendship a friend of the victim takes
the stand in the ohio stage suicide
trial of matthew moore as he faces
murder charges in the 2020 death of his
wife law on crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host terry austin parts of a
document the fbi used to get a search
warrant for former president trump's
mar-a-lago property could soon become
public law and crime's angelette levy is
here with what happened during
thursday's hearing where media
organizations asked for the document to
be unsealed jeanette
terry anytime law enforcement asks for a
search warrant they have to fill out a
document called an affidavit and that
explains the basis for the request for
the warrant well the department of
justice wants this affidavit to remain
sealed they say unsealing it and
revealing it to the public could reveal
the road map of the investigation and
possibly endanger witnesses now you may
recall two weeks ago just about two
weeks ago 30 fbi agents searched donald
trump's mar-a-lago property which led to
an outcry from trump supporters who
claimed it was an abuse of power but
critics of the former president
supported the move saying it's overdue
documents showed that agents seized
classified records some marked top
secret and that president trump was
being investigated for obstruction of
justice and violations of the espionage
act the national archives requested the
return of documents and actually
reviewed some of them several months ago
at mar-a-lago i spoke with a former
federal prosecutor about the request to
unseal this affidavit
typically affidavits are unsealed only
when the target of the investigation is
arrested or the investigation has
concluded so it would be
surprising and really something that
usually does not happen the magistrate
judge were to order the affidavit
unsealed
now that was former federal prosecutor
nima romani who said he was actually
surprised that magistrate judge bruce
reinhardt said that he was considering
unsealing portions of this affidavit
reinhardt told doj lawyers that they
needed to present a redacted copy of the
affidavit to him by noon next thursday
meanwhile a spokesperson for former
president trump released a statement
after this hearing calling for the
release of the full affidavit terry
thanks for that report angenette we
really appreciate it now joining us
today we also have defense attorney and
co-host bernard villalona along with
legal litigator legal analyst richard
schoenstein now bernard i'm going to
start with you as a former prosecutor do
you think disclosing the content of the
affidavit would actually compromise the
investigation
absolutely terry when we're talking
about an affidavit being disclosed on a
matter an investigation that is open i
think it leads to bad precedent bad
precedent in the sense that look it's
going to impede on the investigation the
open investigation witnesses lives are
going to be at danger the investigation
itself in terms of the trajectory of the
investigation is going to be altered
there are so many things to consider yes
the public has a qualified access to
judicial proceedings and judicial
records but when we're talking about an
open investigation where we know the
magnitude
of the cost of the people involved and
people corroborating cooperating it's a
huge issue but we're going to have to
wait and see because again the
redactions haven't been submitted to the
judge and what i see as a former
prosecutor is that that affidavit is
going to be heavily redacted you're
going to be reading that as is has
you're not going to get much information
out of it well you know you're right if
they actually do redact it maybe it
would be okay to disclose but listen
richard i'm thinking that if it's
totally disclosed it would be in the
public's interest to actually see what
the prosecution is claiming don't you
think especially in a high profile case
like this what are your thoughts
i don't know terry i know the public is
interested but that doesn't mean
disclosure is in the public interest
there's a process here and we usually
don't impede in the middle of the
process and start disclosing things
there hasn't been any case filed there
are no allegations there's no indictment
the fbi is at work and i think we should
let them do their work and the other
point i would make is i don't know how
much it would help the public to see
this affidavit especially in a redacted
form we know what's going to happen one
side is going to read it declare that
trump should immediately go to prison
and the other side is going to read it
and say that it proves his innocence
completely it's not going to change
anything to release it well i think the
public is better helped by letting the
process play out yeah actually that's
probably right anjanet was there some
other news about trump's longtime
employees quickly
yeah definitely terry allen weisselberg
used to be the chief financial officer
for the trump organization he pleaded
guilty on thursday to 15 felonies that
relate to a purported tax fraud scheme
he's agreed to testify against the trump
organization at trial he's also agreed
to pay 1.7 million dollars in back taxes
in exchange for serving five months in
jail on rikers island if he doesn't
follow through on that plea agreement he
could go to prison thanks angenet i
appreciate that additional information
let's switch now to connecticut jury
selection resumes in the second civil
trial against conspiracy theorist alex
jones brought about by several of the
families of the victims of the 2012
sandy hook massacre in december of that
year a gunman killed 20 first graders
and six employees at sandy hook
elementary school jones was sued in both
texas and connecticut over comments he
made to his info wars audience after the
shooting he said the shooting was a hoax
and that parents were
staged government actors in an elaborate
ruse to push gun control judges in both
states ruled jones liable for defamation
damages when he failed to respond to
discovery demands and he totally ignored
several court orders the second trial in
connecticut involves eight families and
an fbi agent who responded to the
incident on monday a federal bankruptcy
judge ruled the trial could continue
after jones filed for bankruptcy
protection for the parent company of
infowars the trial is set to begin
september 6.
still ahead on long crime daily a
forensic expert testifies about first
responders devices and the graphic
images at the center of vanessa bryant's
lawsuit against los angeles county
but first disgraced south carolina
attorney alec murdoch demands the
evidence behind murder charges that came
more than a year after his wife and son
were killed
[Music]
welcome back attorneys for disgraced
south carolina attorney alec murdock are
seeking a new court hearing after they
say prosecutors failed to share evidence
in connection with the charges that he
killed his wife and son
last month murdoch was indicted on
murder charges in the 2021 shooting
deaths of his wife maggie and their son
paul shortly thereafter his attorney
requested the prosecution's evidence
court rules required them to turn over
the evidence within 30 days but that
deadline was on monday murdoch's
attorney is now asking the court to
order the state to comply the defense
argues that because it took 13 months to
finish the investigation prosecutors
should already have significant amounts
of evidence ready to send
prosecutors say they want to protect
autopsy information and crime scene
photos from becoming public before trial
although someone in the attorney
general's office has reportedly already
leaked information
richard let me turn to you now
prosecutors have been gathering
information for all of these months what
type of evidence do you think they
should have showing that you know
murdoch actually killed his wife and son
well they got to prove the trinity of
criminal prosecution means motive and
opportunity so they have to connect him
to the guns which is probably forensic
evidence they have to show why he would
have wanted to kill his wife and son
which i believe will tie into all the
mess he was in and they have to show
opportunity i think there's maybe gps
evidence about his whereabouts at the
time that will be relevant here so we're
going to see a lot of different kinds of
things that's right that gps evidence is
really important in these types of cases
now bernard technically defendants have
a right to see the evidence against them
but does the prosecution have to
disclose everything
absolutely terry when we're talking
about a defendant who is on trial for
their life there's an ongoing duty by
the prosecutor to turn over discovery
before the start of any trial this
cannot be a trial by ambush and just to
mention that if a prosecutor fails to
disclose evidence that can exculpate the
defendant that that defendant can
actually get a new trial their
conviction can be reversed so the
prosecutor has to engage in their
ongoing duty of turning over discovery
if there's an issue about a witness
about the safety of a witness they can
always file for protective order or make
it for the eyes only of the defense
attorney and the client so it wouldn't
be disclosed right and not only that
they have to do it in a timely fashion
thanks bernarda all right coming up on
law and crime daily vanessa bryant
versus los angeles county the latest on
the lawsuit from kobe bryant's widow
plus the ohio stage suicide trial of
matthew moore as the victim's friend
takes the stand telling of the last time
she saw emily noble alive
[Music]
welcome back vanessa bryant is set to
take the stand in her civil trial
against los angeles county over the
sharing of graphic images of the
helicopter crash that killed her husband
kobe bryant their daughter gianna and
seven others back in 2020. the lawsuit
claims close-up photos of the remains of
kobe and gianni were distributed on at
least 28 sheriff department devices and
at least a dozen firefighter devices the
county says any photos taken of the
scene were for investigative and
informational purposes only so far the
jury has heard from several first
responders who were at the crash site
after the helicopter plunged into a
hillside late wednesday a forensic
expert testified about those devices
saying some evidence was permanently
deleted when county employees were told
to delete images some responders
obtained new devices at least one was
reported to factory settings deleting
any evidence thursday jurors heard from
los angeles county fire department
officials ahead of vanessa taking the
stand
one denied saying crass comments at the
golden mike's award ceremony about
seeing kobe's burned body another denies
moving sheets to photograph human
remains at the crash site
bernard
what are the strengths and weaknesses of
this case i mean at the end of the day
who do you think is going to prevail
terry i think that the defense is doing
themselves in in this case in a sense
there are so many inconsistencies among
the witnesses that leads to credibility
in the sense of that the jury is going
to be like why are there inconsistencies
why are you lying about things that were
said so that's going to play against the
defense but in terms of what are bad
facts the factory settings on the phone
the deletion of photos from the phone in
terms of the bar video where it shows
that one of the one of the defendants
was showing the photo to someone else so
all of that goes against the defense in
this case what vanessa bryan has working
for her is the emotion it has that no
one ever wants to see that their
pictures of a loved one that has passed
away is being sharing around like if it
were a bunch of cards so i'm hoping that
vanessa bryan at least impunity damages
is able to prevail that's a very good
point i mean at least it would send a
message that you should not be doing
anything like this ever again richard
don't you think in fact that the police
and firefighters should have a policy
that evidence cannot be destroyed
especially if litigation is probable
absolutely i mean as a general matter
everybody should preserve evidence and
that includes everybody on the street
man on the street woman on the street
and it certainly includes law
enforcement and other public service if
there is an incident that is likely that
is in an investigation or likely to end
up in court evidence has to be preserved
there is a slight complexity here
because apparently there was some effort
to reduce the distribution of these
photos that could be a factor as to why
some of the deletions happened but
but apart from that preservation should
be the rule of thumb right i agree one
million percent let's switch now to
florida where the parkland school
shooter is back in court ahead of his
penalty phase trial resuming next week
today's hearing focused on the
defendant's brother and his roommate who
are expected to testify for the defense
back on valentine's day in 2018 the
defendant entered marjory stoneman
douglas high school and killed 17 people
and injured 17 others in october he
pleaded guilty to 17 counts of murder
and 17 additional counts of attempted
murder our jury will now decide if he
receives life in prison or the death
penalty the parkland shooter's brother
zachary cruz and his roommate richard
moore who are set to testify for the
defense filed a motion objecting to
certain questions asked when they were
deposed they argue questioning about
topics such as home family life
political views and participation in
protest movements are not appropriate
and are irrelevant to the case the judge
got a little heated when cruz and
moore's attorneys presented her argument
the bottom line is we want the court to
understand that we feel this is
continued harassment by broward county
and it is tantamount to witness
tampering asking a witness questions
like have you ever been arrested are you
married where do you live i read both
the depositions in full last night
you're saying there's continued
harassment that would warrant the
florida department of law enforcement
getting involved
accusation
which if you feel that's the case then
you ma'am by all means should be
contacting the police yourself to report
this incident
rather than wait and put it on me
in court that's not my job to come to
court and ask me to
i guess empanel a grand jury and open up
an fdle
um
investigation into
what i believe are entirely appropriate
questions that were asked to deposition
that seems a bit far-fetched
the judge ordered both crews and more to
appear for another deposition and answer
the state's questions which she deemed
were appropriate
when we come back a friend of the victim
takes a stand in the ohio murder case of
matthew moore as he stands trial for the
stage suicide death of his wife emily
noble
welcome back testimony on day two in the
murder trial of matthew moore included
friends and neighbors of the couple as
the ohio man faces charges in the stage
suicide death of his wife emily noble
noble was reported missing may 25 2020
after celebrating her 52nd birthday with
more hundreds of volunteers conducted
search parties but more reportedly never
joined in later that year in september
noble's decomposing body was found in a
wooded area not far from the couple's
home she was kneeling beneath a tree
with a usb cord wrapped around her neck
authorities say her death was staged to
look like a suicide but the evidence
said otherwise officials had to use
dental records to identify her body and
an autopsy revealed noble suffered
multiple facial and neck fractures seven
months later moore was arrested and
charged with murder and felonious
assault suzanne kavanaugh a friend of
noble testified thursday morning she
told jurors about the last time she saw
noble more than a year before her friend
disappeared do you recall when the last
time you saw emily west
i believe it was
late winter early spring of 2019. did
you observe anything about emily on that
date the last time you saw her i
observed bruises on her arms did you
ask emily about it i did could you
describe for the jury her emotional
state
based on
what you asked her about the losers
very
defensive
um
our conversation became very heated
the conversation ended with emily
leaving
very upset
i was very upset
and it
it felt like the end of our friendship
i think the testimony from emily's
friend could go either way i mean
perhaps emily was being defensive about
her bruises because they were actually
not inflicted by the defendant what do
you think terri i'm with you on this i
found this testimony very difficult to
interpret and that's partly because of
the nature of it she wasn't permitted to
testify about the actual conversation so
she was asked about the victim's
emotional state and demeanor she said
she was defensive which is not that
conclusive a term i don't know exactly
what that means so i'm left with some
testimony about bruises i don't know how
big they were i don't know how bad they
were and defensiveness that i can't
fully gauge it doesn't really paint a
solid picture for me and i think either
side is open to interpret it i could not
agree more in fact if i had been the
prosecution i don't think i would have
put her on the stand because i think she
helped the defense there now bernarda
there have been multiple deaths and
suicide in this family in fact i can't
believe how many people have actually
died do you think it is possible that
emily actually committed suicide there
were multiple suicides in the family
so terry anything is possible the
problem that you're dealing with here is
that you have the issue of mental health
and mental health not everyone
understands mental health because it's a
concept that's not discussed so i'm
hoping that the jury doing jury
selection they will ask whether anyone
has struggled with mental health or know
someone who has struggled with mental
health because unfortunately for a
person that has experienced so much
death it can go either way either you're
too sad and so broken that you no longer
want to live or you're using that to
live for that person that has passed
because you want to make up for the life
that has been lost so this is a hard
subject for everyone and i hope that the
prosecutor is able to get through and
show that jury that suicide didn't
happen this case because the injuries to
the face don't correspond to suicide i
couldn't agree more now listen thank you
for joining us here on long crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you